[Music]  just months after sister Kim Kardashian  was robbed at gunpoint in Paris the LAPD  tells ET Kendall Jenner's home was  burglarized on Wednesday police received  a call around 115 a.m. thursday morning  that Kendall's Hollywood Hills residents  was broken into and several personal  belongings were missing a source told  TMZ Kendall left her home around noon on  Wednesday and returned around 8pm it  wasn't until Kendall went to her bedroom  around 1am that she realized some of her  jewelry was gone please tell ET there is  no suspect in custody nor is there a  suspect description at this time but  there is video footage from security  cameras Jenner joins alanis morissette  cesar millan and nicki minaj on the list  of celebs who have had their homes  robbed this year  [Music]  you